such an exciting day and we're here to
celebrate this day
and it's an exciting day specifically
for electric vehicles in america i just
have to say we are all charged up
all right
all right that was a joke
and we're here to celebrate
uh because we know electric vehicles are
absolutely an essential tool
if we hope to address our transportation
sector in the emissions both those that
impact climate change but also those
that impact our families our kids
because they impact air quality but you
may not know unless you've driven an
electric vehicle before
that once you drive one you ain't ever
going back
because their performance and the cost
savings they offer to come to our
consumers are absolutely essential as we
move forward it is what is going to make
the transition to an all-electric future
possible and to support this we're
making historic investments through the
president's bipartisan infrastructure
law including the build out of a
nationwide network of five hundred
thousand
electric vehicle charging stations and
through the president's made in america
policies we are spurring investment and
american manufacturing and you know what
that means it means good paying jobs
building electric vehicles and chargers
with
ibew members leading the way
and it's exciting to know that we are
going to make charging stations
accessible across the entire country
whether you're in a rural or urban
community so today
we are kicking off by allowing me the
pleasure of introducing you to jane
hunter who is the ceo of tritium as a
key manufacturer of electric vehicle
chargers tritium is investing in our
electric future and that's a clear
signal that our country has incredible
opportunities ahead of us and i could
not be more excited and we look forward
to working with tritium and others who
are stepping up big time to advance our
climate goals while creating high
quality jobs
right here in the united states jane
[Applause]
thank you gina and good afternoon mr
president secretaries granholm and
buddha judge and of course to jim cooper
from tennessee
it's a pleasure to join you all here
today i'm jane hunter the ceo of tritium
a global leader in dc fast charge
technology for electric vehicles
it would be an understatement to say
that this has been a very exciting month
for tritium
we listed on the nasdaq we rang the bell
on australia day on the 26th and now we
have this opportunity to share tritium's
u.s manufacturing plans with the
american people
tritium is a great story of american
australian partnership continuing our
two countries historic alliance in world
conflicts trade
the environment and technology
the tritium mission is really simple two
words electrify transportation
this vision of transport powered by
renewable energy has inspired our team
since 2012 when we built our first fast
charger
a seismic technology
change is on foot here electric cars
vans buses aircrafts boats these are the
future of transportation and for nations
to prosper and gain economic benefit
from this transition they must be
leaders in both the eevee uptake on one
hand and the supporting infrastructure
and energy rollout on the other nations
that are the forefront of this electric
future will benefit economically and
will see a very substantial improvement
in human health and the environment by
acting rapidly and with courage
and that's what america will achieve
with president biden's bipartisan
infrastructure law
[Applause]
in the 1950s the united states had the
foresight to build the unparalleled us
highway system
this administration's forward-thinking
vision to electrify that system is going
to help american families it decouples
the cost of running the family car or
driving to work from the fluctuations of
the price per barrel of foreign oil
with this charging network in place
americans are going to have access to
fast safe and reliable charging enabling
drivers to cross the wide open planes of
the us the mountains the national parks
and navigate the metropolises from new
york to la
tritium has global expertise
manufacturing and installing fast
charges across 41 countries and we
applaud president biden's ambitious
goals of electrifying the federal fleet
and the equitable deployment of a
national network of 500 000 ev charges
president biden's transport
electrification policies have
contributed to enormous demand for
tritiums products right here in the us
and that directly led us to pivot and
change our global manufacturing strategy
and today we could not be prouder to
announce that we'll be opening a us
manufacturing facility in tennessee
expected to begin production this fall
this facility will have an initial
capacity to build more than 10 000 fast
charger units per year with room to
expand to 30 000
the factory will create american clean
tech jobs employing more than 500 people
over the next five years and we thank
the governor and the state of tennessee
for welcoming tritium with open arms
with the help of the residents of
tennessee we'll be building our largest
factory globally right here in the
united states assembling world-class by
america compliant fast charges made in
america and trucked across the continent
by enabling ev owners to drive anywhere
tritium is going to help fulfill the u.s
target for 50 of new cars sold to be
electric by the year 2030 and will
support u.s economic ambitions to grow
onshore manufacturing in advanced
technologies while also growing jobs
that don't leave anyone behind these can
be trained up in just a few weeks
let me finish up by saying that we're
all privileged to be living in this time
of an historic shift in the way
transport is powered and autonomously
controlled
a bipartisan laws being passed which
will benefit all americans and put
america at the global forefront of this
opportunity
a future with cleaner air quieter towns
and cities awaits the american people
along with more onshore manufacturing
and jobs fuel security and cars which
frankly are just a joy to drive and own
this administration's support for
us-based manufacturing is a smart
economic initiative that will drive
companies to create american jobs and
tritium's a great case in point of that
and we look forward to powering american
evs with american-made fast charges
designed and hardened in the world's
toughest conditions down under tennessee
we can't wait to get started
and now it is my honor to introduce the
president of the united states
[Applause]
jane thank you thank you very very much
i want to thank secretary granholm and
footages and gina mccarthy for being
here today and congressman jim cooper an
old friend who uh did an awful lot to
get this to
get this to go in tennessee
and governor bill lee at tennessee he
deserves credit as well
he wasn't able to be here today but he
worked hard to help make this happen
another example of what america can
achieve when we come together democrats
and republicans to get things done
the new manufacturing facility of
tritium is that's announced today
is more than just great news for
tennessee
yes it's going to create more than 500
good paying jobs in tennessee but it's
going to deliver greater dignity and a
little more breathing room to workers
and their families and it's going to
have a ripple effect beyond and far
beyond the one state
this is great news for workers across
the country for an economy and frankly
for the planet
when we wrote
the and passed the bipartisan
infrastructure law we included 7.5
billion dollars for electric vehicle
chargers
like the one jane brought along today
it's a little thing as you can see
but all kidding aside secretary's grand
home and bootages
have been helping lead this effort from
our administration and later this week
we're going to announce a state by state
allocation for five billion dollars in
the funding for these chargers so states
can start making plans to build out what
will become a national network of
electric vehicle chargers
tritium's new facility is going to
produce up to 30 000 of these chargers
every year
they'll use american parts american iron
american steel and they'll be installed
up and down the highways and carters in
our communities all across the country
by union workers from the ibw and
electric worker and the electrical
workers union
so the benefits are going to ripple to
thousands of miles in every direction
and the these jobs will multiply and
steel mills small parts suppliers
construction sites all over the country
in the years to come and it's going to
help ensure that the american america
leads the world on electric vehicles
china has been a leading race up to now
but this about to change
because america is building convenient
reliable equitable national public
charging networks
so wherever you live
charge an electric vehicle will be quick
and easy
and the foundation will help build help
american automakers set the pace for
electric vehicles which means even more
good-paying jobs producing batteries
materials and parts
that's also going to help save hundreds
of billions of gallons of gasoline over
time
serving saving an average driver who
chooses electric vehicle up to a
thousand dollars every year on fuel
making our country more economically
competitive lowering air pollution and
keeping families healthier as we tackle
climate the climate crisis
here's here's the key point
announcement like this don't happen by
accident they require a vision and a
commitment to build a future that's made
in america
i made it clear from day one
when the federal government spends
taxpayers dollars we're going to buy
american
american products made in america
including american component parts
that's why i established the made in
america office at the white house led by
celeste drake
she's here on the stage where i so there
she is
so let's trade
to ensure that the trillion dollars
we're investing in infrastructure is
spent on american workers and american
manufacturing
on the way over here by the way i was
talking with gina
uh we were talking about uh we have how
many vehicles in the fleet gina roughly
we have 600 000
federal vehicles that we the federal
government owns
they're going to all end up being
electric vehicles electric vehicles
that's what it means to finally make
buying america a reality and not an
empty promise
it means bringing manufacturing jobs
back and building supply chains here at
home
so we have better jobs at lower prices
and it means a federal government that
just doesn't give lip service to buy
america but actually takes action
investing in innovation and
manufacturing which powers up companies
like tritium to do what they do best
create great products and good paying
jobs
that's been my approach from day one
and now we're seeing the results
beginning to see the results my first
full year as president the economy
created 6.6 million new jobs
6.6 million that's never happened before
in american history
and that includes
375 000 manufacturing jobs
2021 saw the highest increase in u.s
manufacturing jobs in nearly 30 years
and let me give you one example
a few weeks ago the ceo of intel
pat
gelsinger came to the white house to
announce a new 20 billion dollar
semiconductor factory that they're gonna
they call a campus outside of columbus
ohio i had the two
senators from ohio here standing with me
one republican one democrat
creating 7 000 construction jobs at that
facility
and 3 000 permanent jobs running the
facility with an average salary running
the facility at
135 000 a year
those semiconductors microchips power
virtually everything in our everyday
lives cell phones automobiles
refrigerators the internet the electric
grid
without semiconductors those things are
not cannot fully function
so the spin-off of this is that we're
going to create thousands of additional
jobs helping build america's products
here in america
manufacturing automobiles and appliances
and so much more
and it's going to help ease inflation
one of the reasons automobiles cost so
much is they're responsible for
one-fifth of the recent inflation is
because they lack semiconductors
they're not able to build them quick
enough so the price goes up higher
because there's fewer to sell
intel's announcement helps us fix that
problem
and intel isn't alone
since 2021 companies have announced
investments totaling more than 200
billion dollars in domestic
manufacturing here in america
from iconic companies like gm and ford
building out new electric vehicle
production to tesla our nation's largest
electric vehicle manufacturer to
innovative younger companies like rivien
building electric trucks or proterra the
building electric buses
which i saw in a virtual tour last year
when i met with the ceo one virtually
and it really impressed me
these companies joining intel bringing
microchip manufacturing back to america
after decades of decay
from texas instruments to samsung and
texas to tsmc in arizona
we're seeing the beginnings of an
american manufacturing comeback this is
not hyperbole this is real this is
genuine this is real
you've heard me say all along when i was
running a sense of god there amer the
world's at an inflection point things
are going to change in big ways this is
one of those transition moments
two weeks ago i went to pittsburgh
where the union pacific railroad
announced the largest purchase for
american-made battery ec
battery a battery excuse me electric
battery locomotives in history
built by
an eerie pennsylvania
and these locomotives aren't only going
to be sold here in america and take a
hell of a lot of heck a lot of pollution
out of the air
they're going to be sold in countries
around the world they're going to be
buying them
just like they're going to buy
american-made electric cars
and just like we heard last week when
boeing announced
20 billion a 20 billion dollar bill
20 billion dollar deal right here in the
white house to sell american-made
aircraft to one of the major airlines in
the middle east qatar airways
supporting tens of thousands of good
paying american manufacturing jobs
so we're seeing the same thing in planes
trains and automobiles
other countries recognize what's
happening here
they want to buy american as well
they're ready to bet on america and
american workers
workers who built the middle class
earning good pay and benefits and the
right to organize
today's announcement
is part of the drum beat of jobs
resurgence like anything more than
anything we've seen before
and by the way house representatives
passed a bill on friday providing over
90 billion dollars for research and
development
manufacturing all those elements of the
supply chain needed to produce end
products right here in america
we can keep delivering more
announcements like this one
and the house and senate are working to
deliver a final to my desk the bottom
line is the united states is in a
position to out-compete the world once
again
i look forward to working with governors
republican and democrat to keep that
drum beat going
so let's keep coming together to invest
in the backbone of america the american
manufacturer and the workers who make it
run
because when we do there's no limit to
what we can achieve none
thank you and may god protect our troops
we've got a lot to look forward to thank
you very much president how was macron's
meeting with putin
how was macron's meeting with putin mr
president